hey guys my name is Jess and it's May
3rd which means we've all got one day to
think of a really good Star Wars joke
for me the fourth nah I've got nothing
guess I'm looking in all the wrong
places first up a new teaser video has
arrived showing off the project Scorpio
dev kit I'll remind you again that this
doesn't necessarily mean that's what the
consumer version is going to look like
but hey it's something the video was
posted on Twitter by just Corden from
Windows central the unit appears to have
a small screen that displays technical
information like the game's framerate
and has buttons to adjust what is shown
on the screen the project Scorpio dev
kit looks quite a lot like the Xbox 1s
which was first pointed out when the
initial dev kit images were made public
in April the more powerful Xbox one
console is expected to launch this
holiday season we're expecting to get a
bunch more information during e3 and
hopefully before so be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss any of that Nintendo
recently announced the new 2d s XL and
now they come out to explain why they
made it Nintendo of America president
Reggie fils-aime told Time the Nintendo
2ds really focused on that entry-level
gamer and we feel with Nintendo 3ds XL
at $199 that it's a fully featured
product that it is if you will the
Cadillac of handheld gaming and then we
heard from consumers a boy I wish there
was something in between and that's why
the company decided to make the 2d s XL
as previously announced the new 2d s XL
does have the same power as the new 3ds
XL the new 2d s XL is set to launch on
July 28th in North America and Europe
and will cost 149 US dollars not to brag
but Australia gets it on June 15 but it
also costs another $50 so when some lose
some
and finally the Fire Emblem remake on
3ds has a $45 season pass and look if
you love Fire Emblem to pieces or not
and go grab it but otherwise I would
quietly or not so quietly recommend you
just go buy another game look that's a
lot of money I'm going to have this
segment up with the most important
information the $45 season pass does
indeed
make the games add-on content more
expensive than the game itself madness
anyway Nintendo has described Fire
Emblem echos shadows of Valencia as a
massive game but if you want it to be
even more massive but picking up the
season pass will grant you a total of
five DLC packs that will add new
dungeons Maps
Story content and classes the first one
will be available on launch day with
three more do out by June first details
on the final pack have not yet been
specified to get some idea of what you'd
get for your 45 bucks the first pack
features a new dungeon and two Maps the
second has another new dungeon and two
more difficult new maps the third has an
unspecified number of new dungeons and
also lets you upgrade characters to
exclusive classes and the fourth has new
story content as part of a prologue pack
that includes new voice acting and maps
I don't know that's all great but I
can't help but think that if there's
enough extra content to warrant a $45
price tag
maybe some of that should have been
included in the base game but that's
just my two cents let me know your
thoughts and feelings on this one in
that comment box that's everything I've
got for you today be sure to head back
to GameSpot or our youtube channel to
check out our new features on hack net
and persona and I will see you again
Laura